hey everyone this video was done in
collaboration with our good friends over
at the tape stick around until the end
of the video to hear more about their
deep dive into Princess Carolyne
what's up wisecrack Jared again in case
you missed it two of our favorite shows
in recent memory wrap this year a good
place and Bojack horseman now on paper
these shows might seem very different
ones a feel-good show about a ragtag
team of dead people trying to save
everyone from member flattening hell
maybe if you score negative points on
earth sorry you blew it enjoy having
your penis flattened while the other one
is about well this prick maybe some of
the troops are heroes but not
automatically I'm sure a lot of the
troops are jerks but what if I told you
that if you dig a little deeper these
shows actually approach the same
philosophical topic from opposite
perspectives oh as it turns out both the
good place and Bojack are preoccupied
not just with death but with how the big
slumber gives meaning to our lives so in
the words of everyone's favorite Florida
man let's hook them all top cocktail the
thing and see what happens
welcome those wisecrack edition on two
ways to die the good place and Bojack
horseman and as always spoilers ahead
now for the uninitiated the good place
has a lot of twists and turns over its
four seasons the show started as a story
about humans mistakenly ending up in
heaven only to surprise us with the
revelation that their good place was in
fact an intricate plot to torture them
but after getting a surprisingly
good-looking demon on their side hello
Silver Fox the show follows the gang as
they try to change the rules that govern
the afterlife that's because the current
system is seriously broken this is the
problem with the current system live
anything less than the most exemplary
life and you are brutally tortured
forever with no recourse the cruelty of
the punishment does not match the
cruelty of the life that one has lived
to fix the problem the judge kind of
like a pseudo God with a daddy complex
last time I checked
I didn't have a dad that's why I'm
attracted to all the father figures on
the TV shows i watch wants to erase
humanity and start from scratch
but the gang manages to convince her and
the folks down in the bad place to adopt
a new system you die go to the afterlife
and then go through a series of tests
before you move on to heaven at the end
you're given a sort of evaluation and
the architects explain what you did
badly what you did well and then you get
rebooted and do it again and again and
again until you ace it all's well that
ends well right not so much well the
gang may have stopped all humanity from
going to hell that doesn't mean that
heaven is all that great in the words of
Hypatia of Alexandria paper this is
paradise all your desires and needs are
met but it's infinite and when
perfection goes on forever you become
this glassy-eyed mush person living
forever is kind of its own hell so
Eleanor has a solution a way to restore
meaning to the people in the good place
is to let them leave in other words for
your afterlife to have meaning
you too must die or in this case cease
to exist the show wraps up with our
heroes all doing what they need to feel
at peace before shuffling off this
immortal coil now if you think it's
strange that a show about the afterlife
ends with everyone essentially dying
that's probably because you're not
familiar with this guy mortality offers
meaning to our lives and morality helps
navigate that meaning wait what I think
it says is that mortality offers meaning
to the events of our lives that dude
right there is Todd Mei who's not only a
professor of philosophy but also a
philosophical adviser to the show with
Pamela harana me
it's Mays book death that actually
provides the philosophical framework for
the series ending in it may makes the
bold claim that the fact that we die is
the most important fact about us
formai death provides a unique structure
to our lives
with death subsuming all other facts
about our lives without death he argues
we would all lose a sense of meaning and
maybe even virtue to prove the point may
asks us to consider jorge luis borges
his short story the immortal which
follows a man named joseph kartoffel as'
in search of a river that grants
immortal
but when kartoffel is finally drinks
from the river and discovers his society
of immortals he's shocked to find that
they're just a pathetic husks of former
humans they barely talk show strikingly
little interest in others and wander
about in the literal ruins of their own
civilization if this sounds familiar to
you maybe that's because it reminds you
of this delightful character in the good
place multi-ball
I mean it's perfect
we're all having orgasms literally all
the time I died a virgin so that's real
crazy because there's nothing that the
residents the good place haven't done or
will not eventually do during that
eternity nothing provides them meaning
or joy even the literal constant cosmic
orgasmic bliss or go-karting with
monkeys monkeys are the ideal go-kart
opponents they're funny enough to give
the finger but not smart enough to win
perhaps worse this unending life seems
to also strip people of their identities
Hypatia of alexandria for example
becomes the exact opposite of an erudite
ancient philosopher she swapped her toga
for an NFL jersey goes by the name Patti
and has totally forgotten the name of
her former profession but it's not just
our passions that eternity would numb
May sights fellow philosopher Martha
Nussbaum and speculating that eternity
could even chip away at our moral
concerns going so far as to speculate
that even justice would be imperiled the
needs of others would not urge
themselves on us in the same way since
their existence would not be threatened
by our neglect this is certainly the
case in Bohr has his story where car
topless relates how a man was left at
the bottom of a ravine for almost a
century because no one could be bothered
to get him out after all why rush when
you have until the end of time and while
the good place didn't quite bear this
thesis out it's interesting to note that
after an eternity
Chiti who made moral philosophy his
whole life on earth and the afterlife
was no longer interested in studying the
subject once he got to the good place
after thousands of reading the most
difficult writings in the world I've
acquired a new passion garbage books do
you think it would have been a good
symbologist if there were a real job but
the good placement odd may both agree
that eternity is a less than great
everything needs in it
may for his part asks his readers to
consider a novel a book concluding isn't
important in and of itself literally
every book in existence has a final page
but this ending itself lets you reflect
on what came before and gives you a
chance to order that experience or we
can consider your typical TV sitcom the
fact that there's a final scene to each
episode isn't surprising but building to
that end allows the episode to have a
narrative drive and a sense of closure
for the good place the knowledge of
finality allows the show and its
characters to create meaning the chance
to walk through a door of non-existence
allows Jason to feel complete when he
played the perfect game of madden after
over 400,000 tries and it allows Chiti
to feel at peace when he and Elinor sit
down for their last dinner together as
Michael paraphrase Elinor you said that
every human is a little bit sad all the
time because you know you're gonna die
but that knowledge is what gives life
meaning but if all this seems a bit
overly well optimistic then maybe Bojack
horseman z' perspective would speak to
you more afterall Bojack has spent six
seasons deconstructing the idea that
anything in life can be neatly wrapped
up let alone in the face of death funny
isn't it things that matter matters and
the truth is it all matters tremendously
it's a wonder any of us ever get out of
bed at all and yet we get out of that
and the final half of season six is no
different
while Bojack seems to have turned a new
sober leaf as a drama teacher at
Wesleyan everything goes south for him
when two intrepid 1930s style reporters
start poking around his past what begins
as a story about bojack's involvement
and saralyn's death quickly spirals into
a PR nightmare with Bojack getting
grilled for all his horrible behavior on
national TV when she was intoxicated you
had sex with her and when she was sober
you gave her the heroin that killed her
then in an effort to cover for yourself
you waited to call the paramedics that
might have saved her life
one relapse later complete with a
near-death experience and one of the
best dream sequences on television and
Bojack has been sentenced to 14 months
in jail the series ends with Bojack
being released for a night to attend
Princess Carolyn's wedding where he must
accept the fact that life doesn't have
any rhyme or reason he just simply has
to get by yeah what are you gonna do
life's a [ __ ] and then you die right
sometimes sometimes life's a [ __ ] and
then you keep living it's that last
sentence that really encapsulates the
philosophical essence of the show life's
a [ __ ] and then you die or sometimes
you just keep on living
unlike the good place there are no
clear-cut endings in Bojack horseman no
real moments to get a greater sense of
closure sure Bojack might make a big
gesture of change at the end of one
season whether it's saving Todd from an
improv cult or showing kindness to his
mother on her deathbed but he always
slides right back this place was
supposed to be a fresh start for me
rehab was supposed to be a fresh start
but no matter how many starts I get
there's always the same ending
everything falls apart and
I end up alone simply put endings in
Bojack offer little to no meaning so
it's not too surprising then that death
the end of all ends is likewise treated
as a frightening meaningless unknown
this all harkens back to the early
French variety of existentialism to
paraphrase the original bad boy of
French philosophy jean-paul Sartre
humans are created without any specific
purpose unlike toilet paper which is
obviously made to be bought and hoarded
like precious gold we enter this world
without any rhyme or reason and only
define ourselves afterwards but whatever
one finds in their quest for meaning
it's all for naught as the cosmic
curtain comes to a close some
existential nihilists even go a step
further and say why bother searching at
all and the words of philosopher Donald
Crosby stretch fret and delude ourselves
as we may our lives are of no
significance and it is futile to seek or
to affirm meaning where none can be
found while existential nihilism is as
far away as possible from todd may's
argument that death gives life meaning
it's been a constant staple for Bojack
in fact death punctuates almost every
season with the deaths of herb cos as
Sarah Lynn and bojack's mother all
causing Bojack to hit new emotional lows
and subsequently scramble to make sense
of his life I don't know how to be Diane
doesn't get better and it doesn't get
easier but it's season 6 where the show
really drives the existentialist message
home particularly in the episode the
view from halfway down after Bojack
relapses he breaks into his old home
takes a bunch of pills drinks a bunch of
vodka and then has a near-death
experience while drowning yeah I kept
having this dream where I was having
dinner with all the people who were gone
and I thought I should do that
in the dream Bojack has dinner with all
the people he knew who died also zach
braff is the waiter water Thank You Zach
Braff what starts as a dinner game about
the best and worst parts of the
characters lives quickly devolves into a
conversation about the value of these
lives
saralyn insists that all the joy she
brought her fans must mean something
while corduroy Jackson Jackson you know
the guy who hanged himself while jerking
off and sucking on a lemon says it can't
equal bojack's uncle's sacrifice you
you singing songs on stage it's the same
thing as this guy who died liberated
because their Apple to Auschwitz is
notably this isn't the structured kind
of philosophical conversation we would
see play out in the good place or an
answer or resolution is always found at
the end of 22 minutes instead there's no
agreement no answers here bojack's
father represented by Secretariat says
it best what they did with their lives
didn't matter all the time those people
spent trying to do good or help people
will be something I did none of that and
yet here I am same as them regardless of
what they did on earth or who they were
they all died and he attempts to create
meaning or to find peace or just
desperation peace
that's someone trying to convince
himself of something of what the life
has meaning or purpose that but if you
check the right boxes and do the dance
and you get a little parting gift at the
end a frame certificate that says
congratulations you've got peace of
course Bojack is anything but at peace
when he realizes he won't be waking up
from this dream you're not coming
oh this is always the part where I wake
up you all go to the show Zach Braff
says part of my reach even though he can
clearly get my plate from another angle
then I wake up okay
instead Bojack joins the others for a
literal show one by one the characters
perform an artistic rendition of their
deaths
saralyn sings a song about how you
shouldn't stop performing until you're
dead corduroy hangs himself and
Secretariat /bo Jack's father reads a
haunting poem about jumping off the
bridge
thrash to break from gravity what now
could slow the drop halt I'd give four
toes to touch the safety back atop at
the end of all these performances the
characters exit through a door of
non-existence but this door isn't the
serene wooded variety we see in the good
place
it's an abyss it's a stark contrast
where the good play strives to tell us
that death will be peaceful and that
you'll go willingly what will happen
when we go through it well we don't
really know exactly all we know is it
will be peaceful and your journey will
be over Bojack implies that it's
terrifying and you're going whether you
want to or not
now while it might be tempting to chalk
this all up to bojack's
traders being a bit more artistic in
their visions of death these choices are
actually integral to existentialism most
existentialists argue that if meaning
exists in the world it is an entirely
human construct according to Sartre when
we perceive the world around us what
we're actually doing is trying to impose
order upon it he writes it's our
presence in the world which multiplies
relations it is we who set up this
relationship between this tree and a bit
of sky thanks to us that star which has
been dead for millennia at that quarter
moon and that dark River are disclosed
in the unity of a landscape more
importantly existentialist argue that
this mental process is what allows
humans to be free sure there's no grand
purpose to our existence but that
doesn't mean we can't attempt to create
one for ourselves and the artists who
distills their vision of the world onto
a canvas or a stage is perhaps the most
free of all it explains why so many
existentialists like Sartre Camus and de
Beauvoir were also playwrights and it
explains why herb tells Bojack this
during his dream has anyone ever come
back from this place PJ there is no
place it's just your brain going through
what it feels like it has to go through
all you can do right now is sit back and
enjoy the show none of this was real it
simply Bojack creating art from his life
trying to impose order in the end
Bojack has to come to the sobering
realization that this is it
see you on the other side
there is no other side this is it of
course Bojack doesn't actually die and
maybe that's the point think back to
maze point the idea that death gives
structure and meaning to a life if a
person never died if the book never
ended if the show just went on then at
what point will we be able to sit back
and ask ourselves what does it all mean
ultimately the good place chose a sitcom
ending one where the characters all
completed their journeys and found peace
even if that meant their existence is
coming to an end
I just suddenly had this calm feeling
like the air inside my lungs was the
same as the air outside my body it was
peaceful in Bojack the show ends but the
journey continues even Bojack doesn't
really know what he's going to do or how
it's going to be but it's easy now in
jail I don't have to make any choices
for myself I worry about what's gonna
happen when I get out we keep coming
back to that line from the final scene
sometimes life's a [ __ ] and then you
keep living in the last scene
Bojack confronts the reality that he'll
never totally make things right with
Diane but even so life will go on as if
proving the point the last moments of
the show are an uncomfortably long shot
of the two sitting awkwardly next to
each other in silence so here's the
million-dollar question wisecrack and
asking how death affects life why did
the good place end on simple answers and
why did Bojack end with open questions
strangely I think the answer lies not
necessarily in the show's themselves but
in their creators and more importantly
their mediums after all the good place
is the baby of Michael Schur one of the
most influential figures in American
television sure cut his teeth on the
American office before creating Parks
and Rec Brooklyn nine-nine and the good
place in other words he's an
honest-to-god sitcom genius but sitcoms
as a form have their own narrative
demands Dan Harmon's said it best when
he wrote that TV isn't selling
revolution it's selling a hygienic
relatable substitution for your own
filthy unmarketable humanity the trick
that television plays is that it swaps
out any meaningful and therefore
potentially television subverting truth
with the basic eternal truth that change
unnecessary ultimately the traditional
TV model is focused on placating
audiences TV wants to make you feel good
even safe about your life's that you'll
watch more TV the last thing it wants to
do is create an existential crisis but
this is exactly what Bojack horseman
does and it's precisely because the man
behind the show Raphael bob-waksberg is
not from Hollywood in fact like many
existentialist bob-waksberg is a
playwright by training and as a result
Bojack uses theatricality the episode
times arrow for example freely draws on
theater inspirations like Harold Pinter
and Carol Churchill by depicting
Beatrice's dementia as her mixing and
mashing various moments of her life
another episode free churro is
essentially a one-man show a 20-minute
monologue in which Bojack delivers a
eulogy about his mother Beatrice and
it's also one of the top TV episodes of
all time on IMDB even bob-waksberg
penchant for theater and all its
existential baggage it's not surprising
that Bojack shoes the easy answers and
happy endings of network TV closure is a
made-up thing by Steven Spielberg to
sell movie tickets it's like true love
and the Munich Olympics doesn't exist in
the real world the only thing to do now
is just to keep living forward in the
end we get a very interesting dichotomy
the good place attempts to be a show
about philosophy even the starting
premise for people stuck in hell
torturing each other is inspired by
jean-paul Sartre's famous play no exit
yet because of the show's sitcom roots
it's bound to answers that can easily
fit the sitcom mold of clean endings it
wants to soothe us with the traditional
sitcom logic that it's all going to be
okay as long as we have our friends or
as Chiti puts it
[Music]
but maybe we should just be excited that
any show network television or otherwise
is willing to talk about Conte what are
you reading
the metaphysics of morals by Immanuel
Kant
it's a treatise on the aesthetic
preconditions of the minds receptivity
to duty on the other hand Bojack
horseman is the exact opposite of the
good place it's a show set in Hollywood
that because of its theater roots ends
up being about philosophy and to be sure
we never get the answer to a lot of
questions is there meaning to the damage
we experience are we doomed to always be
the people we are now and but in all
seriousness just as the show leaves us
uncertain about how bojack's journey
will go it leaves us uncertain about the
meaning of life death and any other
deeper philosophical questions and in
that there's a certain genuineness and
authenticity that the good place lacks
still itching to learn about every nook
and cranny of Bojack horseman is genius
be sure to check out the takes video on
the only person who somehow stayed
friends with bow Jack Princess Carolyne
it explores the working woman trope she
embodies and her unique relationship to
storytelling the take has a ton of cool
videos exploring the tropes that are
everywhere in your favorite movies and
shows they've got a whole bunch of
videos on the good place Bojack and my
absolute favorite the matrix click here
to check them out be sure to subscribe
and tell them wisecrack sent you thanks
for watching everybody
peace